one crisis after another for Donald
Trump's administration some of his own
making others like the mass shooting in
Las Vegas out of his control my guest
here in Washington is the Republican
congressman Don bacon how long is he
going to put up with a president who's
proved so divisive to so many
[Music]
don't bacon welcome for conflict zone
thank you for having me a year ago you
didn't want Donald Trump to be president
you condemned his comments in the so
called Access Hollywood tape in which he
described sexually assaulting women do
you still think he's fundamentally unfit
to be President
well what I actually said was I didn't
think he could win because of that
statement so I thought it was maybe
better for pence to stand up but I
always said you said his words were
utterly disgraceful and disqualifying
they were disgraceful but I was telling
his Hillary Clinton I always thought I
would vote for him over Hillary Clinton
cuz her conduct was also disqualifying
but you say those two you said Trump
should allow a strong conservative
candidate like Mike Pence from the
Republican Party to win in November you
weren't giving him any second chances
here I actually do you so regret that
he's president I actually did though I
said if it's gonna be between him and
Hillary I'm voting for him over Hillary
and I said that okay but you still
rather he wasn't that I would prefer him
over Hillary Clinton that wasn't that
wasn't the question congressman well I
think it but it's why you still how do
you still have profound regrets about
him being president I thought that
statement was disgraceful but I think
he's doing a good job as president and
so I support him with his policy issues
but in the end when you're having a
picket president it's between two people
and it was him in Hillary Clinton I
thought he was a better choice you gave
him a pretty soft time over his highly
controversial comments about the
violence recent violence in
Charlottesville Virginia say when he
said there was violence on both sides
you said I worry about the vitriol in
this country on both sides as if you
like the president were saying that both
sides were just as bad as each other
well you know you have to remember just
a few weeks before that my good friend
Steve Scalise was shot by someone from
the loft and I was just saying that
there is vitriol on the left and the
right now I condemned the racism those
who support rate any white Nazi or a
race Ku Klux Klan I condemn what the
President did too and I think what he
meant was that the but there there is
virtue on both sides and I think both
sides got to do about her
I seriously think there's an equivalence
between Nazi white supremacists shouting
Jews will not replace us and those who
oppose them there's an equivalence
between them no there's not an
equivalence and I would have been on the
side of those protesting but they should
not have done it in a violent way and
that's I think that was the president's
father who drove a car protest and he
was wrong
and I and you know what and those were
the whites need to be told that he
should be held accountable and the
president condemned white Nazis Ku Klux
Klan not and I did too but there is
vitriol on both sides and I and I saw we
saw with Steve Scalise getting shot by
someone who was inflamed by leftist
groups in the wake of Chavez Ville v US
Joint Chiefs issued unprecedented public
condemnation of white supremacist groups
not both sides they didn't talk about
both sides being violent or vitriol on
both sides they didn't equivocate but
you couldn't bring yourself to do that
could you you took the president's line
I can dumb white Nazis Ku Klux Klan
period but you basically implied that
there was Fault on both sides because
the other because this is what I said
you can protest Nazis and Ku Klux Klan I
would have protested with those folks
but we do not have a right to violence
and do on that I believe in Martin
Luther King's message of peaceful
protest and we need to see that when
you're protesting even when we're on the
right we do not have a right to to go to
violence that would be that's that was
the intent of my calles other people in
your party were much stronger in the
condemnation of both of what the
president said and what the white
supremacists were doing Senator Lindsey
Graham warned that Trump's words were
dividing Americans not healing them
senator bob Corker chair of the Foreign
Relations Committee he questioned the
president's stability and competence
Senator Marco Rubio
mr. president you can't allow white
supremacists to share only part of the
blame it's your duty to call out evil
when you see it isn't it you know Nazis
are evil make it clear here if it's not
clear enough Nazism Ku Klux Klan both
are evil and you
the president made that point yes he
said he made that statement he's he does
ievel he he condemned Nazis and Ku Klux
Klan but I think the intent of his
comment was even we protest against them
we should do it in a peaceful way I
don't think we don't want violence as
part of our so what he sees on potti
condemned him why do you think his
business councils collapse why do you
think the president of the afl-cio said
I cannot sit on a council for a
president who tolerates bigotry and
domestic terrorism you know I I give
them the right to speak their mind to on
that I think it's all right to disagree
on this stuff
I believe the president was making it
clear that Ku Klux Klan groups Nazi
groups are important but to extend those
comments horrify people in America and
around the world and senior members of
your party I think there's there's media
folks like you who like to twist those
words and I think that that's part of
what's good thing anything I'm quoting
the words he put it he did say he said
there were fine people on both sides
didn't they you know there are people
among me and I think he should be more
clear but he was saying but I do I take
his statement
honestly when he said that Nazis and Ku
Klux Klan were abhorrent were repugnant
I think he used the word repugnant and
revolting Kenneth's phrase ahead of
Merck pharmaceuticals also resigned from
the Business Council he said I feel a
responsibility to take a stand against
intolerance and within 54 minutes the
president shot back well now that Ken
Frazier of Merck Pharma has resigned
he'll have more time to lower ripoff
drug prices I think that's an
appropriate response that's probably not
how I would answer that you went before
Congress to appeal for civility I think
we should kind of civility you had in
mind
I think our president should have a
brazed of our civility but socially both
parties he's do I think he's dropped
let's face I would say but I I would say
that if I was him I would work on
raising the bar of civility a lot of his
supporters want someone who fights back
too and you're seeing that tug-of-war
right now my way is to I'm a
conservative I believe in making my case
in a civil way so I would I don't take
it the same way but I know a lot of us
Porter's wants the ones who fights back
yeah that's one of the reasons he got
elected Peter Wayne a former advisor to
George W Bush now at the ethics and
Public Policy Center here he said we've
never had a president who so relishes
producing animosity and hate among
Americans and who does it so
consistently so gleefully and so
intentionally he's right as Lee I would
disagree with that I think that that's
on what places it's it's it's totally
one-sided kind of comment I think that
we have to look at someone in their
totality now what I talked exactly the
way Donald Trump the president Trump
does now it's not my style I would I
wouldn't have probably wouldn't have
done well as a commander speaking that
way but he does have a large segment of
support that wants him to fight back
and that's what we're seeing or see I
think of the reason souther think back
to the gold star family the cons that he
insulted the parents of a servicemen who
died fighting for his country think back
to Senator John McCain's war record that
he trashed and you really think wine is
Wayne as judgment in Selma I would say
in those cases I don't think the
president should have been those
comments I thought they were
inappropriate as well the problem isn't
just about civility it's about lies as
well as them and the president has lied
consistently over so many things how do
you cope with that I mean how do you
spin that to yourself which lies you
want to talk about February the 4th
let's take an example
13:40 tweeted after being forced to
apologize for its bad and inaccurate
coverage of me after winning the
elections the fake New York Times is
still lost only one problem
the New York Times didn't apologize
March the 7th 122 vicious prisoners he
said released by the Obama
administration from Guantanamo have
returned to the battlefield another
terrible decision you know what I wish
some was 113 we released by Bush not by
Obama but there has been about a third
of our Guantanamo prisoners have gone
back on the battlefield so I think
that's the intent of their comment July
after his speech to Boy Scouts mr. Trump
said I got a call from the head of the
Boy Scouts saying it was the greatest
speech that was ever made to them it was
news to the Boy Scouts because they'd
already apologized for the political
content in his speech that's a lie
ah you know I'm not part of that I
wasn't part of the discussion oh you
sell that to say you've given the
president your full support you said at
the beginning I support this president
yes I support the general those kinds
around our country and I support the
general conservative message and the
themes are each taking us I want to
lower our taxes I want to fix our tax
code
I want to strengthen our military but
what about the role of Congress to hold
the executive to account
I mean you you'd never have let a
Democrat do you think we should impeach
him no I'm just about to tell you that I
think okay you would never have let a
Democrat get away with not revealing his
taxes not releasing his taxes you
wouldn't have is there is there a while
that says he has to do it nobody
promised he promised in turn 2014 he
said if I decide to run for office I'll
produce my tax returns absolutely never
did well here's here's the thing I you
know if it was me I would I would put
out my taxes you know but we do do a
federal disclosure process is very
extensive I think I can't remember how
many pages hisses that's pretty pretty
extensive but in the end am I gonna put
my emphasis on focusing on the taxes
he's following the law he's doing what
the law said I want to put my focus on
fixing a broken tax code getting her
military back on its feet that was
broken under this previous
administration that's where I choose to
put my might focus
what are America's allies to make of
this president or doesn't it matter what
they think you know the rest of the
world is pulling away from America
Angela Merkel in Germany's her comment
after meeting Trump earlier this year
the days when Europe could rely on
others was over to a certain extent that
was what is a true assertion we see a
lot of leaders who support him too I
mean just look at Israel I mean that
relationship with Barack Obama was
broken we're seeing a rear approach but
what those are all again and I don't see
it we see the French leadership
initially it was strained but that
rapport has become butter I think we're
seeing a good rapport in the Far East
with China right or not China excuse me
uh Japan so I would disagree with your
assertion the Pew survey ladies Pew
survey among 37 nations
June showed an average of just 22% of
people had confidence in Trump to do the
right thing in international affairs
that's a massive downturn
it's not about America disastrous loss
of confidence in the United States
this happened on his watch I would just
say that your assertions of that
leadership is doubt the case but yeah I
think if it's 22% I haven't seen our
poll number that wouldn't be good we
should be I wish it was better what are
the allies to make of his disrespect for
his own intelligence services for
instance over Russia he still sometimes
refers to the whole hacking issue as
hoaxes are they to make of that I may
make about disparaging comments about
NATO
he called it obsolete yeah but you know
I think we've seen it that tone change
what you heard there was a campaign
theme I disagreed with it I think NATO
is very important and I said I disagree
with it publicly well when he said it
however I would say is where he's at now
I think he's in a better spot with NATO
but the one thing that he was good on
with NATO a lot of countries only a few
countries were paying of the 2% GDP and
I think that he has some focus on
getting there so there's been some
goodness too with some honesty and some
kandra's they've got up to 2024 to raise
their spending and we're seeing a lot of
countries do that and what he said in
February he said the money is coming in
like never before so the money is coming
in I think we're seeing an improvement
do you think there was room for
improvement for what NATO was spending
on defense yes how disappointed are you
with the lack of progress on the
Republican legislative program I'm
thinking of the the failure to appear
repeal Obamacare much trumpeted both in
the campaign and since Trump took office
the legislative programs in tatters is
there I think that health care it is and
I think it's discouraging I think we
expected better out of the Senate I know
five of the six senators who push back
against the the bigger bill had
campaigned to repeal and replace so yeah
I wish there was better work there I am
I'm committed to continuing the effort
to work on health care because of the
small business community the farmers
real estate agents anybody that's on the
individual market
they're suffering I love her pain 30,000
a year in premiums and then even more
with deductibles so we have to fix that
but there was huge hype wasn't that
congressman well the president's
beautiful plan was just everything to be
implemented wasn't it there was a
commitment to get this done and I and we
did not get it done
so my view of it is and so if taken one
big bite at the Apple like we were
trying to do we need to do multiple
different bills that are smaller more
targeted because the folks are on the
individual market are crying for relief
and we can't just walk away
so I'm committed to continuing working
on health care and we have 24 different
bills that I am supporting co-sponsoring
that will provide some relief to those
that are paying there on the individual
market because we committed to it now I
wish to settle what I got the job done
but it didn't happen so you know we got
it we got to come back and figure how
we're gonna rebound and - the smaller
bills we'll get it done one of your
colleagues Republican colleagues in
Congress mark meadows of North Carolina
he said last month if there was ever a
time when Republicans feel pressure to
perform it's now if big things don't get
done by Thanksgiving there's really
won't be enough spin to say Republicans
here have done anything but fail well
that's that's quite an indictment isn't
I think we have all the arms of
government you have a Senate you have
the House of Representative you have the
White House you have 25 out of 50
governorships in the state and you can't
pass as the New York Times said anything
more than renaming a post office these
days well I would say we've done more
than that however I think the premise of
mark Meadows comments there's a lot of
truth there there we have to get tax
reform done I think was the underlying
theme of that comment and so we're gonna
be working hard on that to make that a
reality out of house Patrol again we got
to go through the Senate but there has
been other work done out of the house
the house has passed more bills than
what's been ever passed in the last 20
to 30 years we've done a lot of work on
regulatory reform we've done a
dodd-frank reform we've gotten the
military back on the line of getting
back to on their feet and getting
healthy again
what we what we have to do is get some
of those things out of the Senate before
there'd be progress so I would say there
is I generally would agree with mark
models there we got to get more results
the public wants more results done daily
poll last week said 78% of Americans
disapprove of the job Republicans doing
in Congress only 15% approve do you hang
your head in shame when you I don't like
that I think 15% approval
you know I'll bake Indian in the house
is it I know the house has delivered on
everything we said we would do so I know
that we've done our job in the house but
I know also most of the people in the
Senate the ones I work with and know
well they've done everything they can to
bottom line is we got to keep working
and what the public's not buying it are
they no but you know I personally know
that I doesn't that matter well it does
matter but I would say that I've done
everything I could do on the key issues
I have voted right in the house has
delivered on those key issues we have
delivered on regulatory reform we did
deliver on health care reform out of the
house we did what we said we were gonna
do we delivered on dodd-frank reforms we
got our military back on his feet so the
house has delivered and I wish we did
have better results out of the Senate
and we got it so we can't stop we've got
to continue working it what are you
gonna do on gun control
after the appalling mass shooting in
Vegas what are you gonna do there well
first of all I was turned bit repulsed
at the immediate partisanship that came
out I think we should have given it a
few days first of all let's get the
investigation wasn't the usual thing
Republicans say give it a few days wait
for the public to lose interest in wait
for the heat to get out of the issue and
then we'll do nothing again I was
talking to some my Democrat colleagues
yesterday who were appalled at some of
the comments that were made because we
should give it time to know what kind of
guns did the guy have we don't even know
what motivated them yet there's so many
things that we should learn before
jumping to conclusions in the end this
guy was evil this is your way of saying
you're not gonna do anything about no I
think we should know the facts I'm not I
don't believe in doing something without
facts maybe we do I don't last year the
House of Representatives as you know
staged a sit-in on the floor of the
house
protest the fact that you wouldn't let
your party wouldn't let two votes on gun
control go to a vote is that what you're
gonna do again I'm not gonna sit on the
floor protest no but it was the
Democrats who did and I got a lot done
didn't it
it didn't get anything done well I think
that's that's the point they were
protesting it the fact that your party
wasn't doing anything about this yeah in
the end I we do have a Constitution and
I'm gonna be a defender of the Second
Amendment I do think there are some
areas areas to reflect like for example
the ability to modify a gun nut to be an
automatic weapon I think that that's a
discussion point that we need to have
hot
well hot why did ATF make the conclusion
that that's legal and so I I'm signing a
letter today San ATF why did you do that
what was your background reasoning
should we not reconsider because in the
end I think that was a big part of this
issue though I think we should hear from
the investigation but when you can
modify a semi-automatic into an
automatic weapon
automatic weapons are illegal so I think
that that's an area that we need to
delve into and I think we can fix I'd
like to hear both sides of that issue
though but in the end we're gonna I
think we want to enforce the laws we
have you know we have a man you took you
signed a bill the president signed a
bill in February actually making it
easier for the mentally impaired to get
guns you know the very 28th the VFW in
the American Legion agreed with us that
that was throwing veterans that should
not have had their gun rights taken away
under the bus you want the mentally
impaired to may know which is the access
to guns we should have due process
before how would you like if someone
said you're not only to say we're taking
your gun don't you have a due process
that the regulation did not have due
process to it and so if you've got a
group of 20 people and you had one or
two people that perhaps should have
their guns taken away the other 18
shouldn't have their guns taken away
though could and that's what this but
that's what that regulation was doing
was throwing a lot of people under the
bus taking away their second Amendment
rights so there's got to be due process
to this and that's what that's what we
voted for let's talk a little bit about
foreign policy you've called the nuclear
deal with Iran deeply flawed you held
out the possibility that Iran could have
a nuclear weapon within ten
years general mattis your defense
secretary doesn't agree with you he was
asked the other day in Congress if he
supported America's thing within the
deal he said yes Israeli intelligence
experts who you've often cited and
you've said you admired them they also
say but this deal has been good for
Israel no no that's not true
that's not copy Gillen I've heard of
Israel's Dina who myself about this so
calmly Guillory commie Gilan former head
of Israel's domestic intelligence the
Shin Bet he said in July that at the
two-year anniversary of a nuclear deal
the threat of an Iranian nuclear weapon
is more remote than it has been in
decades
I just no president or a prime minister
netanyahu and i met with his team this
summer i think that that agreement is
deeply flawed it's gonna give Iran a
nuclear weapon roughly in ten years or
legitimize a nuclear program well Mike's
away it's delayed in enormous ly if it
ever happens I think in the end what we
did is we kick the can down the road to
legitimize Iran getting a nuclear weapon
and we give them 150 billion dollars
back immediately so they got everything
they wanted right up front for a
promised or something down the road I
agree with Prime Minister Netanyahu that
this agreement as a minimum has to be
renegotiated we should never say it's
agreeable to us that Iran have a
legitimate nuclear what a program Iran
has dismantled and removed two-thirds of
its centrifuges what's wrong with that I
think that that's good it has reduced
its stockpile of enriched uranium by 98%
shipping over 25,000 pounds out of the
country what's wrong with that I think
that's a good that's good the core of
its Arak reactor which could have
allowed the country to produce
weapons-grade plutonium has been removed
the shell has been filled with concrete
what's wrong with that I think that's
good sounds like a great deal that your
this thing it's a temporary improvement
in the end Iran wants to have a nuclear
capability I think they're working with
the North Koreans in the meantime and
this 10-year hiatus we should never of
legitimize them as a nuclear power and
that's what this agreement did and we
gave them back a 150 billion dollars
immediately for a promise for something
that they may do over ten years I think
what were our children grandchildren are
going to suffer a grave threat with Iran
nuclear capability versus Iran they've
they've committed to
the annihilation of Israel their
leadership has so I think this ability I
think that agreement is deeply flawed
let's talk about Israel for a moment you
said earlier in the interview that
President Obama was hostile to Israel
how hostile is it to sign the
largest-ever military assistance package
worth 38 million dollars equipping
Israel's Air Force with advanced f-35
aircraft maintaining its military edge
there's a lot of countries on the
roundtheworld would like that kind of
hostility from the United States that's
hostile that part the agreement itself
was reasonably good there was a lot of
commitment are things that they were
Netanyahu was not allowed to come back
to Congress to make any more requests so
there were a lot of other stipulations
in that bill that I found a little
distasteful a muscular a longtime
Israeli Defence official retired from
government service said it's easy to
criticize Obama but on the military
front the relationship was incredible I
think there was I do say there was a
good rapport at the military level and I
was a part of that
I hope stand up missile defense in
Israel contrast that with a Republican
president Donald Trump who carelessly
gave away one of Israel's secrets on
Isis Prime Minister Netanyahu said the
relationship of the United States and
Israel is the best it's been in a decade
I may also have endangered the source of
that intelligence you think that was an
intelligent thing for the president to
have done yeah we should be very careful
when we're talking about classified
information I would agree aren't you
worried congressman that when in future
people look back if this presidency ends
badly
we're going to look back and think who
gave Donald Trump an easy time who
failed to hold him to account who didn't
criticize it like some members of your
party are criticizing you worried that
you're going to be on the wrong side of
history you know I believe in
criticizing when it's right and I don't
believe in criticize jumping on a
bandwagon in the end this is what I want
to do I want to get tax reform done I
want to give you think you're actually
gonna get done give it a work yard the
record so far I'm gonna work hard at it
and I want to work I want to continue
working on reforming our health care
system that is broke I want to work on
getting our military strong again and
that's where I put my focus a lot of
folks like yourself evidently want to
focus on the Twitter and this and
I don't think that that in the long run
is constructive I want to get big policy
issues done and that's where I put my
focus but this is what I camp in our
districts don't you disappointed with
way you've got to here disappointed in
what disappointed in the legislative
program that we talked about it's in
tell us I am disappointed with the
president who keeps changing his mind
about everything nobody believes Senate
did that get health care reform done I
am NOT disappointed that the house the
house performance we have passed every
bill that we set out to pass so I feel
good about what we've done out of the
house and granted it we have a two house
system so we got we got to get things
through the Senate and I agree that that
is disappointing congressman's don't
make it it's been good to be on comm
thank you thank you very much have a
good day
[Music]
you
[Music]